can you are exactly like Ryu and you are
wholly unnecessary what on average each
participant costs my side of things
about $52,000 just help me with the guys
upstairs and give me fifty two thousand
reasons why we need two guys at do the
execs have a sign man can you give me
fifty two thousand reasons why why we
need you uh uh can Ryu do this if you
kick my desk again I'm gonna hit you
with this phone I'd like to see you try
if you attack me I will crush you
that's what I say Dale that's what I say
it's gravy boy I'm the gravy boy I'm the
gravy boy this boy's mashed potatoes
okay guys will line up with the rest of
the kids very case just a fire drill you
look like meg Ryan 90s meg Ryan
so now eat the logic of the sketch it's
night if you early Niners yeah but I
don't understand what a meg Ryan is you
know you should put your pens top down
cuz the inks gonna go to the bottom
doesn't matter you worked in an office
no I just I'm a pen guy this paperwork
this is one fighter okay this is Sagat
Saget like my personal friend Bob Saget
Hey you're friends with full House's Bob
Saget no I'm friends with America's
Funniest Home
me and full house Saget do not get along
stay sentimental mm-hmm it's way too
Center